[Music]
being Spider-Man is a sacrifice do you
have a choice between saving one person
and saving an entire world I can do both
this year you can't run forever kid send
everyone the spider War we are supposed
to be the good
comes just as much as Spider-Man as any
of you all stations stop Spider-Man
across the spider-verse miles when wanna
get out of here wait wait there's an
elite Society with all the best fighter
people in it I'm Spiderman oh no way all
of us are do I have web on my face
what's the deal what's the guy I gotta
do to join this spider team we don't
belong out there don't even get me
started on Doctor Strange and a little
nerd back on Earth 1999.99 what
Spider-Man across the spider verse did
this day get any weirder
I guess it can my name's Miles Morales
I'm Brooklyn's one and only wait a
second
I gotta go shoot I have to go
send everyone
Spiderman across the spider-verse
exclusively in movie theaters
foreign
[Music]